Je ne vote pas le neuf/06,
c'est-ce qu'on entend
beaucoup ces derniers temps dans les médias,
c'est la journée de l'Europe et dans 1 mois
on vote pour les prochaines élections européennes.
Et même si ce n'est pas les présidentielles,
je vais te donner quelques raisons
pour te montrer qu'elles sont plus importantes
justement que les présidentielles.
Par exemple, l'Union européenne,
elle joue 1 rôle primordial
dans la lutte contre le rejetement climatique,
notamment avec le pacte vert,
faire des décisions comme consommer plus local,
réindustraliser notre territoire et cetera.
Union européenne
permet également de renforcer notre démocratie.
Ça peut par exemple être donc la condamnation donc
des violences faites aux femmes,
aux enfants ou encore aux personnes LGBT.
Alors pourquoi ces élections sont si importantes ?
Et bien parce que
toutes les décisions prises au parlement
doivent ensuite s'appliquer à chaque état membre.
Par exemple le droit à l'ivg, ou chaque état donc
doit respecter ce droit.
Je ne sais pas pour toi, mais moi je vote le neuf/06.
Si tu as besoin d'en savoir plus sur ces élections,
n'hésite pas à me le dire en commentaire
ou à te rendre sur mon compte
où je présente donc les
programmes de chacun des candidats